ya nos acompaña también en el estudio
Juan pupiales como gran conocedor de
toda esta trama que involucra a la
estrella del fútbol mundial por
excelencia Lionel Messi que ayer
decepcionó a los culés pero digamos que
hizo feliz a los estadounidenses no sé
oigo mucha decepción mucha insistencia
en ese tema de excepción por parte de
los aficionados culés Messi por primera
vez va a abandonar el fútbol de Europa
después de haber pasado dos años en el
París saint-germain tiene 35 años llega
el Inter de Miami para un contrato que
amenaza ser pionero en el fútbol de
Europa para analizar ese tema conectamos
con Caracas en donde se encuentra María
Luisa María Alicia Ruiz que ya es
directora de icon Brand management y que
también es el marketing manager de
gravis Vázquez quien fue el tercer
venezolano en haber llegado a la NBA
María Alicia Muchísimas gracias por
estar con nosotros
Hola qué tal un gusto Juan roce Daniela
Cómo están Gracias por la oportunidad
Gracias a ti Alicia no sé quién de los
dos quiere empezar si empezamos por lo
económico por lo deportivo Bueno yo sí
tengo mucha curiosidad en este tema
porque
me llama mucho la atención como una
persona decide irse a Estados Unidos y
rechazar una oferta millonaria que le
estaban haciendo en Arabia Saudita Por
qué pasa esto bueno Messi es una persona
también muy Familiar no hay muchas
aristas Más allá de la parte económica
detrás de esta decisión como saben
Lionel Messi es un culé Yo estoy de
acuerdo con Juan yo soy una de esas
personas dolidas porque no está en el
Barcelona pero realmente su salida del
club Catalán no fue la mejor se fue el
París Saint germa en dos años donde
demostró que él nos fue feliz donde su
familia no estuvo 100% a gusto y también
a lo mejor irse Arabia Saudita a través
de una propuesta multimillonaria no era
lo que realmente Él y su familia querían
es por eso que él toma la decisión de
irse a Miami lo declaró en las
entrevistas que se que se hizo a Mundo
Deportivo que también fue una decisión
personal donde él quería hacer el propio
dueño de Su futuro y y por eso termina
estando en Miami cosa que era un rumor
no mucha gente piensa que que esto es
algo nuevo y no desde el hace dos años
cuando él sale del Barcelona ya el Inter
de Miami sonaba como posible un posible
Club para el jugador argentino María
Elisa me gustaría profundizar
precisamente Cuáles son las ventajas que
le ofrece El inter Miami frente a los
400 millones de euros que le ofrecía el
fútbol Saudita Cuáles son esas ventajas
que económicamente le trae el llegar a
este Club
Sí es que es un día que no es netamente
la parte del sueldo que él va a estar
recibiendo que son cuarenta millones de
dólares por temporada sino que también
no sé si saben que Apple TV cerró un
acuerdo con la mls del MLS paz que
simplemente tú vas a poder ver la mls a
través de la aplicación de Apple TV a
partir de ahora todos suscriptor que
llegue a Apple TV a la mls pass va a
tener un revenue Messi de todo lo que
venga y De igual forma con Adidas toda
Jersey sin que se mueva de Adidas de
Lionel Messi pues va a recibir un un
porcentaje de eso es decir que el
acuerdo no Simplemente la parte que él
va a estar recibiendo como salario sino
todo lo que viene
aunado a eso no y De igual forma va a
tener la posibilidad de comprar un
equipo de fútbol en la mls replicando un
poco lo que hizo David Beckham En el
2007 con l Galaxy que en este caso
compró el Inter de Miami y él se le
preguntó precisamente por los beneficios
que tiene este fichaje de Messi pero
para la liga estadounidense de fútbol no
para para que aumente el interés por
este deporte en Estados Unidos no no sé
si saben que también Estados Unidos
dentro de cuatro años va a ser el Host
de lo que va a ser la copa del mundo en
el 2024 va a ser el Host también de la
Copa América donde Miami es una de las
principales es a nivel deportivo Miami
es una ciudad que se está moviendo
muchísimo tenemos el Miami Heat en la
final a los Florida panthers que
llegaron a la Stanley es decir hay
muchas cosas que están ocurriendo dentro
de esa ciudad y la llegada Lionel Messi
simplemente llega a repuntar mucho lo
que se está haciendo ahí no incluso les
tengo datos interesantes los tickets
para ver ahora el Inter de Miami han
aumentado Aquí les tengo la la cifra mil
seiscientos noventa por ciento más un
ticket solía costar 30 dólares y ahorita
puede estar en el promedio de 500
dólares Este es el impacto que está
teniendo Lionel Messi en la mls Y por
supuesto en el Inter de Miami María
Alicia Entonces esto podría verse como
un buen entre Lionel Messi y también en
la liga y en ese en ese En ese sentido
también quiero preguntarle cómo Este
modelo si es un modelo pionero primero
que todo y si va a seguirse dando en la
industria de que ya no solamente llega
el jugador y le pagan sus salarios sino
que además viene con otros incentivos
diferentes esto de participar
directamente en los ingresos es algo muy
novedoso totalmente Pero bueno Esto es
algo que realmente el primero que lo
instaló fue Michael Jordan a través de
toda su marca Air con Nike y es algo de
lo que somos familiarizados no y
simplemente estas grandes figuras como
Lionel Meza incluso Lebron James las
están trayendo y yo creo que esto es uno
de los atractivos de poder traerlos a
esta parte del del continente por
supuesto sabemos el sueño de todo
futbolista estar en la liga europea en
las mejores ligas poder disputar una
Champions pero traer figuras como Messi
Messi ha dicho que quiere traer aparte
de lo que habían sido sus compañeros Di
María dibu se está hablando que a lo
mejor podría venir y yo creo que esto va
a subir mucho más el nivel de la mls y
bueno nos va a dar otra liga que podamos
empezar a ponerle el ojo no así que sin
duda para mí es el gran ganador de todo
esto va a ser la la mls sin sin dudarlo
y el gran perdedor de todo esto está
haciendo el fútbol Saudita el fútbol
Saudita venía de buenas noticias fichar
a Cristiano Ronaldo ficharon a Benzema
consiguieron que el Tour de la PJ se
mezclara con el circuito el Live Golf
que está financiado por Arabia Saudita
todo parecía ir bien para que este este
proyecto Saudita se consolidara pero no
llegó esta derrota de Messi no pudieron
atraer al campeón del mundo Qué supone
esto para los planes de Arabia Saudita
bueno Esto también demuestra que el
dinero no lo es todo y que al final de
cuentas los atletas También tienen que
evaluar otro tipo de cosas Al momento de
tomar su decisión Messi no es cristiano
Messi tiene un un entorno familiar
distinto lo ha demostrado en cada una de
sus oportunidades sin decir que uno es
mejor que otro ojo pero bueno él toma
mucho en cuenta eso recuérdese que la
cultura de Arabia Saudita no es la misma
que el occidente y él piensa mucho en el
bienestar de su familia de sus hijos y
Bueno realmente Messi tiene dinero o sea
eso vamos no y creo que este tío que le
está ofreciendo el Inter de Miami es
también a largo plazo no son inversiones
es la parte tiene inversiones
inmobiliarios En en las en Florida
entonces Bueno realmente era una
situación del del poder continuar a
estar cerca también está mucho más cerca
de lo que es Rosario Argentina Messi
suele ir mucho para Argentina y otra
cosa que dijo ayer Es que él no descarta
de alguna manera el poder retirarse como
quería en el Barcelona entonces
mantenerse de este lado del hemisferio
creo que es algo que pueda apuntar a
Esos planes o bueno ya sea más a futuro
aportar de alguna manera al club culé
María Alicia yo que siempre estoy detrás
del del lado económico de las noticias
en este caso también hay algo que me
llama la atención es como Arabia Saudita
para quedarnos también ahí cómo era vía
Saudita está diversificando sus
inversiones para desligarse un poco del
petróleo porque el deporte y cómo ha
sido como está puesta que le está
haciendo Arabia Saudita al deporte es
que el deporte conecta el deporte no
tiene color no tiene raza no tiene
nombre es decir todos vibramos a través
del deporte también no es secreto las
múltiples denuncias que han habido en
Arabia Saudita que hubo con el tema de
Qatar y el deporte fue una vía para
poder taparlo no y y realmente es la
mejor forma donde tú puedas invertir
dinero y de alguna manera limpiar la
carga por decirlo de alguna forma No no
estoy diciendo que todos lo estén
haciendo de esa forma pero es un
vehículo para eso y están viendo que es
una oportunidad de negocio miren todo lo
que movió el mundial de de Qatar y todo
lo que se convirtió no entonces también
es otra forma de dar conocer este país
No solamente es el punto de vista como
tú dices petróleo que es el principal
producto por el cual se conoce sino
también todas estas ventajas que están
teniendo a nivel deportivo Y por
supuesto en el mundo del turismo no
entonces simplemente es la mejor opción
cuando tú desees reinvertir dinero y
llamar la atención el deporte es la vía
perfecta Porque todos conectamos por esa
vía María Elisa ya hablamos de lo que
supone para Estados Unidos está Apuesta
por Messi de cara al Mundial de 2026 de
Cara a la Copa América que tenemos el
otro año pero me gustaría pedirle un
poco de contexto de Cuál es la situación
del Soccer del fútbol en Estados Unidos
que es un país en donde el fútbol
americano está en una dimensión
completamente fuera por delante de otro
deporte que también hay hockey que
también hay béisbol en qué momento se
encuentra el fútbol en Estados Unidos
bueno el fútbol ha ido increyendo de
verdad que ha sido bastante sorpresivo
como ha ido los estadios se han estado
llenando yo no sé si han podido seguir
mucho en la planta United donde
particularmente tenemos un venezolano
Joseph Martínez que estuvo allí fue
jugador franquicia que hoy en día está
en el Inter de Miami va a poder
participar con con Messi y los estadios
estaban full no y el Soccer al final es
un deporte que conecta con la
generaciones menores lo que es el
NFL conecta mucho con audiencias mayores
no entonces el Soccer tiene el reto de
llegarle a esa franja mucho menor verdad
de lo que está ocurriendo Entonces es
una liga que va en crecimiento en
expansión la llegada de Messi sin duda
es algo que va a revolucionar totalmente
Esto se está hablando que incluso van a
cambiar el primer partido de lo que
sería el Inter de Miami al Hard Rock
Café que cabe alrededor de sesenta mil
personas para que puedan cumplir con la
necesidad de Ver a Messi cuando han ido
a hacer giras el Real Madrid el Bayern
en el Barcelona los estadios se estaban
repletos y es por la necesidad de ver
estas grandes figuras entonces una
apuesta bien interesante va van creyendo
como les digo y yo creo que nos puede
dar una sorpresa bastante grata en
futuro cercano María Alicia pues se nos
acaba el tiempo para continuar con este
tema que como usted dice trasciende lo
puramente deportivo Muchísimas gracias
por este análisis tan completo y tan
interesante No gracias a ustedes por la
oportunidad y aquí a la orden para lo
que necesiten